helmut z der freut sich auf seinen
fernsehabend auf der couch als er nach
einem langen tag auf der baustelle auf
seiner auffahrt wiegt es ist da schon
dunkel und nur die scheinwerfer des
lieferwagens beleuchten den weg bis zu
seinem haus am waldrand was er da nicht
ahnt im haus lauert ein einbrecher auf
ihn sebastian prengel mit den recherchen
nur knapp hat helmut den angriff des
einbrechers überlebt eine riesige
operationsnarbe zieht sich über seinen
bauch genau dort wo der täter am 14
dezember zugestochen hat habe ich ihn
gepackt runtergedrückt dass strache auch
schon zu dem ozean selbst noch einen
notruf absetzen auch wochen nach der tat
ist er geschockt wenn er über den
überfall spricht
eingeweide gesehen habe ich wieder
reingedrückt eine notoperation rettet
wenig später sein leben der einbrecher
entkommt ohne beute mit reporter
sebastian prengel geht auf spurensuche
versucht die flucht des offenbar
jugendlichen täters zu rekonstruieren
nach der flucht durch den wald ist der
einbrecher hier in dieser wohnsiedlung
angekommen es war dunkel und der
gangster hatte immer noch die tatwaffe
bei sich die musste er loswerden und das
hat er hier auf diesem grundstück getan
denn hinter diesem haus da steht eine
gartenlaube und da hat er das messer mit
dem er auf den hausbesitzer eingestochen
hat versteckt er ist dann weiter auf das
nachbargrundstück hat sich hier
kurzerhand ein weißes fahrrad gestohlen
und ist dann weiter in diese richtung
geflüchtet
welchen weg er genau genommen hat ist
nicht ganz sicher er könnte entweder mit
dem gestohlenen fahrrad hier durch
dieses waldstück und dann durch ein
wohngebiet gerast sein oder er ist über
einen feldweg gefahren fest steht die
polizei glaubt dass auf der lippstädter
straße möglicherweise ein fluchtwagen
bereitstand es gibt eine zeugen
beobachtung von 18 05 eine dame hat dort
gesehen wie ein weißer transporter mit
einem rot blauen logo einer düsseldorfer
installationsfirma dort mit überhöhter
geschwindigkeit die straße lohkamp
passiert hat der brutale einbruch in
bielefeld ist kein einzelfall eine
unheimliche raubserie erschüttert
nordrhein westfalen prominentestes opfer
entertainerin verona pooth und ihre
familie am weihnachtsabend brechen in
meerbusch bei düsseldorf fünf täter in
die familienvilla 1 die fünf männer
hinterlassen ein feld der verwüstung
schlagen alles kurz und klein stehen
schmuck wertgegenstände und taschen im
wert von mehreren hunderttausend euro
seelenruhig klauen sie auch veronas fiat
500 der auf dem grundstück steht
man kann nicht einschlafen die gedanken
kreisen immer wieder darum dass die
leute in dem haus war nur einen tag
zuvor hatten die einbrecher offenbar
schon die nachbar villa ausgeraubt
weiterer einbruch schwerpunkt ist die
gemeinde roetgen bei aachen seit anfang
dezember wurde hier bereits 23 mal
eingebrochen die täter steigen meistens
tagsüber am hinteren teil der gebäude in
die privaten räume sie hebeln
terrassentüren oder fenster aus schlagen
scheiben ein dann laufen sie durchs haus
suchen nach geld und wertgegenständen
die einbrecher ziehen kreuz und quer
durch das ganze dorf die einwohner leben
in ständiger angst das nächste opfer zu
werden
[Musik]
wenn sie nach hause wieder kommen und
sie sehen die tür ist aufgebrochen die
steht auf das kann eigentlich nicht sein
oder das fenster steht auf das habe ich
doch zu gemacht dann könnte es sein dass
eben einbrecher da gewesen sind oder
noch in den räumlichkeiten noch sind
bitte nicht reingehen schützen sie sich
da bitte selber gehen sie zurück suchen
sie einen sicheren ort und rufen sie
bitte direkt die polizei über die 110
genau das wurde helmut in bielefeld zum
verhängnis er hofft dass sein brutaler
täter gefasst wird die polizei bittet um
mithilfe wir bitten die bevölkerung
natürlich nach wie vor um hinweise die
uns bei den ermittlungen weiterhelfen
können wir suchen nach wie vor nach
einem jungen mann der sich wie wir
bereits wissen bei der tatausführung
verletzt haben dürfte und zwar in der
form dass reste dieser verletzung auch
am heutigen tage noch zu sehen sein
dürften in denen der tatverdächtige
vielleicht noch eine verbundene hand
oder ähnliche verletzungen aufweist ja
und der chef der mordkommission hat das
gesagt die polizei fahndet weiter nach
dem einbrecher hinweise an die kripo
unter 0521 5450
und natürlich fragt sich jetzt nach
diesem stück jeder wie mache ich denn
jetzt mein haus meine wohnung sicher
mohammed khamis der mann den wir ihnen
gleich vorstellen arbeitet heute als
sozialarbeiter früher war er aber selbst
einbrecher und für uns verachtung
fahndung schlüpft er noch einmal in
dieser rolle und zeigt wie genau die
ganoven vorgehen der erste gang vom
einbrecher ist immer direkten schlaf zu
machen
im schlafzimmer
aufmachen von innen an drucken von unten
unter die schubladen runter ans bett
gleich
bettdecke hoch nicht einfach so da
schaut man ist da irgend etwas
auffälliges gehört jeweils nicht kann
sind irgendwelche klettverschlüsse beim
kamin würde ich versuchen überall wo ein
hohlraum ist das zu öffnen und da rein
zu sehen oder im innenbereich des kamins
da kann man zb man hat hier diverse
möglichkeiten etwas reinzulegen von
daher ist der kamin auch ein risiko das
bücherregal
ist zum einen ein
suchfeld innerhalb der bücher dass man
das buch aufklappt und einfach so ein
bisschen rum wedelt es kann aber auch
sein dass hier eine zweite wand ist wenn
man die bücher rausnimmt dass hier zwei
wände sind in dem regal hier würde ich
einsehen nachsehen was da ist das reicht
das große abtasten da kann man hier noch
gucken
ist hier eine doppelte wand hier sind
reisedokumente und krankenkassenkarten
man kann damit zum arzt gehen oder
jemanden zum arzt schicken dass ich was
nicht leisten kann oder
handyvertrag holen oder 10 oder
vielleicht sogar ein auto man kann aber
auch jetzt aus aktuellem anlass an
flüchtlinge die vielleicht so aussehen
wie die bestohlene person kann man auch
die ausweise verkaufen
welche die holen sich eine alarmanlage
und mit einer außen sirene das ist das
kein vorteil sein das heißt ich habe
hier etwas zu beschützen da würde ich
lieber empfehlen im bereich des hauses
in ein kleines licht anzubringen was
ohne jede bedeutung oder ich würde ein
paar schuhe unterhaus zu stellen um
besuch vorzutäuschen als letztes gibt es
immer die einem die aufkleber beim
einbrechen
verändern sollen hier war er wacht mein
nachbar oder wir haben eine macht sein
und dürfte zumal kostenlos bei der
polizei und man kann sich nicht
vorstellen wie effektiv so etwas ist ja
[Musik]
also schuhe vor die tür stellen und der
aufkleber bringen mehr als die
alarmanlage